[Applause]
good morning welcome to day two of being
material the second biennial symposium
of MIT Center for art science and
technology in 1995 Nicholas Negroponte
II who joined us yesterday predicted a
future where being digital would mean
that our lives would be evermore shaped
by what he called the global movement of
weightless bits at the speed of light
negroponte use book tracked a shift of
actuation and signification occurring on
the level of atoms to a domain of
meeting created in bits yet unwieldy
matter persists and reasserts itself
during the symposium so far we've heard
about wearable technologies programmable
instruments and musical productions that
reflect the ways the properties of the
digital inflect our understanding of the
physical and material and vice-versa
in today's sessions on the livable and
invisible which I'm honored to co-chair
with Professor Stefan home rave we
continue to think in different ways with
artists scientists technologists
humanists and others about the tangible
thingy substances that comprise the
material world I'm pleased to introduce
the first panel this morning which will
take a variety of approaches toward the
world of living material from
researching living things to engineering
them understanding and managing
Assemblies of life are the core concerns
of a spectrum of academic study in
addition to corporate enterprise
politics and activism the environmental
conditions that foster life may be
treated as resources to be harnessed as
safeguards against scarcity the matter
of artistic inspiration or pattern forms
for thinking about the built environment
and the artistic and technological
design of urban landscapes was one of
the core concerns of capiche
when founding CA BS which we heard about
yesterday the category of the natural
environment may additionally be
understood as a resource that must be
actively preserved
a message foundational to earth day
which we celebrate this year with a
March for science at the conclusion of
today's symposium events and we will
have sign making activities and
materials available so that everybody
can participate in that
well the Boston March for science logo
features the Zakim bridge over the
Charles River
it's the massive bridge that we will
cross today as MIT anti-vietnam
protesters did in the 1960s surrounded
by sky art inflatables by former MIT
based artist Otto Pina
as I introduced today's panelists I'd
like to reflect on Tina's words about
the importance of materiality in an
increasingly immaterial sphere of
artistic practice
he said not all art has to be in
material to be mentally expansive and
mentally productive to deal with
immature reality for any artist you have
to know everything about materiality
this morning's panel on livable
materials assembles conversations about
the cultural incubation of life across
fields of biological design networked
ecology environmental remediation and
political economy we're joined today by
child anita director of the synthetic
biological systems laboratory at
columbia university tell us a synthetic
biologist to engineer some of the
smallest scale forms of life in the form
of dynamic environmentally responsive
programmable bacteria also with us today
is Claire Pentecost professor
photography at the school of the Art
Institute of Chicago Clare's artwork
involves research into agriculture
ecology and the tangle of relationships
between humans and other beings and
matter in her words we are walking
communities and our health is connected
to the world our third panelist this
morning is film our Dean of the School
of Social Sciences at the University of
California Irvine bill is a cultural
anthropologist of law property and
finance examining how monetary practices
commoditized unexpected aspects of
social biological and ecological life
his investigations of currency explored
the value placed on
trol resources in as much as the
parameters of the field of anthropology
the study of social and cultural life
itself all shedding new light on what it
means to make a living
conversations about the material
entanglements of body and environment
nature and culture resource harvesting
and environmental impact have become
ever more urgent here to frame matters
these matters of historical scientific
and cultural inquiry that comprised the
livable session is our moderator patinas
doser assistant professor in global
studies and languages at MIT
Bettina is an anthropologist who works
on the intersections of ecology
globalization and urban life she will
frame the panel to come with some
introductory reflections about how
livable material is defined from within
and without
through forces of desire appraisals of
value and assertions of solidarity
please join me in welcoming Bettina
up to the podium
[Applause]